[Music]
hello
welcome to this session on building the
right api team
as part of this video we'll talk you
through our recommendations when it
comes to forming your api team
their responsibilities and the various
roles involved
so to start things off let's take a look
at the digital value chain
you might have seen this diagram before
but to briefly explain
the digital value chain shows the
relationship between the various teams
and technologies
from the end consumer all the way down
to the backend systems
for this session we'll be focusing
specifically on the api team
shown here in the chain the api team
builds
yep you guessed it the apis
this is the team that will be working
directly with your api platform
to create lovable apis for your app
developers
in terms of responsibility the api team
owns
five core areas first is building highly
consumable
apis the key word here is consumable
we recommend approaching api design and
implementation from the outside in
rather than the inside out what this
means
is that the api team will always need to
keep the end consumer in mind
when approaching apis in the case of our
digital value chain
this is the app developer the api team
should always be asking itself
if i are an app developer what type of
apis would i want to consume
second is learning and applying best
practices to the apis that they will be
building we promote a variety of
industry best practices when it comes to
the design
development and the deployment of your
apis
please refer to the docs page or our
self-service training on cocera
for additional details third is
engagement
similar to our focus on consumable apis
the api team should be engaged with all
the players in the digital value chain
this includes backend system teams which
the apis will front
to the app developer in order to gain
valuable insights to unearth areas of to
further iterate on
and to enhance your existing services
scalability is also very important when
it comes to your api program
oftentimes we see that the api team
starts small
but grows rapidly as more and more
demand comes down the pipeline
in these scenarios federation becomes
very important
the api team owns the creation and the
management of materials that allows for
the entire organization to rapidly scale
this includes things like the api
playbook automated test suites and more
finally api should always be improving
by leveraging capabilities of the
platform such as analytics
the api team can gain valuable insight
into who's using the apis
and how this information allows the api
team to find areas of improvement
and enhancements based on real data that
they are seeing
remember our focus on consumability this
information can help
a lot with that we strongly believe in
the fast and iterative approach to
development
market shifts happen rapidly and your
api team needs to be able to adapt
and be flexible in its delivery approach
as a result we recommend a methodology
such as agile for your program
similarly the api team is composed in a
similar fashion to a standard scrum team
a diverse set of perspectives is also
very important which we'll cover in more
detail when we talk about roles
having different viewpoints that
encompass the business technical
and operational views will streamline
your api development process
so now that we've covered the basics
let's jump into the individual roles of
an api team
there are five main roles when it comes
to a good api team
they are the api team leader the
architect
the api developers the evangelist and
the extended team
let's spend the next few minutes going
over each one the api team leader is
essentially your product owner
now note that i said product owner and
not project manager
as mentioned before the api team we're
suggesting is based off the standard
scrum model
so the api team leader is essentially
your product owner in scrum
as such the team leader should be
aligned with both the business
and the it and have a good understanding
of the needs of the end consumer
for example the app developer the team
leader also helps create
refine and prioritize the scope for the
api team
when it comes down to it the team leader
will be the one that makes the call
if trade-offs are needed in the event
that the api team
doesn't have the bandwidth to complete
all the items the architect is critical
to the api team
not only do they bridge the gap between
the api team leader and the api
developers
they also establish and enforce api best
practices
and keep a common design cadence their
approach to the api design
is consumer focused and educates the
wider api team
on how to leverage the api platform in
summary
they're part designer part teacher and
part enforcer
the api developers is your core
development group
at the end of the day these are the
folks that are going to get the job done
the api developers will look to the api
team leader for guidance
on the scope and the architect for their
design principles
they will then take those inputs and
build out the actual apis
as you would expect the api developers
should be very familiar with the api
platform
without the api developers nothing will
get built so
be sure you're nice to them the
evangelist is the mascot for the api
program
they are responsible for not only
outreaching to your api consumers
but also creating and nurturing a
developer community
they can provide valuable feedback from
the field which can then directly
impact the direction of the api program
a good evangelist will be critical in
expanding the audience of your apis
both within and outside of your
organization the extended team
is also very important in getting your
apis out to production
the extended team covers organizations
such as security
qa operations and others the extended
team
and their processes may vary depending
on how your organization is set up
but the key takeaway is that these teams
should support rather than obstruct your
time to market
so before we wrap up let's cover some
common attributes that all successful
api teams have
first a successful api team should have
the support of an executive sponsor
chances are the api team will continue
to push the envelope
of innovation within your organization
so having a strong executive sponsor
can help clear any of these roadblocks
that they may face
when challenging the status quo second
the api team should be solely focused on
apis
we often see api teams consist of
developers who are also shared with
other projects
this not only can lead to issues with
resourcing and bandwidth
but also affect the direction of your
apis such as cutting corners and
striving away from best practices
third there must be a willingness to
train others within the organization
as your api program grows so will the
demand
this in turn can lead to an influx of
apis that would need to be created
or enhanced chances are the api team
that you start off with
will expand and as new members are
brought in they will need to be trained
on the foundational design philosophies
you've already established
in the world of apis and the
consumer-focused approach a consistent
api experience is key
fourth the api team should have a direct
line to the business
there shouldn't be any silos between the
business and technical teams
it makes sense right if the api team has
a better understanding of the business
vision
and the impacts to the end consumers the
better the apis will be
since they will ensure that the business
vision is properly achieved
finally the api team should be free from
pre-existing constraints
as we mentioned before the api team
should strive on innovation
and not be constrained by outdated
governance models or
processes in the world of apis time to
market is critical
so welcome change rather than trying to
fit it within an insufficient process
in closing we totally understand if the
concepts discussed in this video may
seem a little challenging
especially if you already have a
governance or delivery structure in
place today
remember that the start always requires
the greatest effort
but if you can overcome these challenges
and embrace the ideas we just covered
you'll have a more robust and innovative
api team
thank you
you